[Musique]
le festival zéro déchet bat son plein à
montréal en fait depuis hier c'est une
troisième édition pour ce festival donc
la comédienne ève landry a mené la porte
parole
elle était avec nous ce matin vont jouer
un jour d'abord pourquoi avoir accepté
d'être porte parole ça va vous
interpellez se doucher leurs
complètement givet à chaque année puis
quand ils m'ont approché je leur ai
demandé pourquoi pourquoi moi je suis
pas une spécialiste zéro déchet je me
suis jamais autoproclamé tél et on dit
ben non justement tu représentes la
jeune famille qui essayent qui ont aussi
que je suis conscientiser gens n'ont
souvent que je fais quand même des
efforts que je pense que ça c'est connu
fait que les autres ils voulaient juste
mettre l'accent là-dessus montré que les
familles vous avez des enfants - c'est
un défi complètement fait que d'autres
sur ce qu'il voulait miser essayer de
montrer aux gens que c'est le petit
geste on pense moins que le petit geste
pas d'importance mais si on est
plusieurs à le faire les gouverneurs
mais les gouvernements auront pas le
choix de voir cet impact la cette
mobilisation la de la population et
d'agir en conséquence donc en allant
voir les grandes compagnies qui
produisent énormément parce que je
trouve tellement que c'est enrageant
pour le citoyen de faire son petit geste
de face de moi je me casse la tête pour
essayer de rentrer ça dans l'horaire est
de voir les grosses compagnies qui
continue de produire qui continuent de
polluer c'est peut être en jean pour le
citoyen mais c'est important de croire
que notre mobilisation vaut avoir un
impact sur le gouvernement pour pouvoir
ensuite faire des gros mouvements est
truqué qu'on peut commencer avec des
petits gestes à la maison d'ailleurs
comment ça se concrétise le zéro déchet
vous d'abord vous vous dites pas zéro
déchet
maintenant je n'atteins pas le zéro
déchet encore gîte en gîte en le plus
possible - ya plusieurs gestes que j'ai
posée en trop bon comment je pense tout
de suite aux people parce que c'est la
grande fierté de ma fille on a des
petits piments
c'est pas grand chose mais elle est
tellement content puis un matin et
maudit moment il y en a plus d'un an
maman doit faire le lavage c'est ce
photographe people et donc moins de
papier de toilette pour ma fille et moi
qu'est ce que d'autres aussi qu'on ne
change bien et le vrac jeu
je suis toujours au marché un demi-pouce
c - organisation compenser ça devient
peu naturel moi mon pot est fini je le
mets je le sais que c'est mon pot dry a
c'est vrai j'ai besoin de riz mais quand
je repasse jamais tout mais pau puis je
le sais chaque pot et pourquoi donc
l'expérience n'est pas l'épicerie les
mains vides on arrive à l'épaule oui
exactement à l'épicerie pis c'est pas
vrai aussi vous entends souvent en
région oui mais nous on n'a pas accès
non j'ai pris une famille en région et à
saint-andré-de-kamouraska au dépanneur
de dubrac maintenant si il y en a de
plus en plus c'est plus accessible qu'on
pense et même à l'épicerie tu l'as le
vrac et s'agit juste de parler un peu
peur de parler à vos commerçants ils
sont beaucoup plus parlant comme
indépendant l'impression de bouger une
grosse machine une grosse industrie
c'est pas mal plus incompris on sent
qu'il ya vraiment un mouvement dans les
épiceries on voit des boucheries qui
acceptent de plus en plus écologiques
qui vous avez j'ai bien quelque part que
vous vous sentirez plus souvent
qu'autrement coupable qu'est-ce qu'elle
geste vous verrez le plus de culpabilité
moi c'est les couches je m'en sors pas
les couches j'ai essayé je me sens
coupable avec mes couches chaque couche
qu'ont certaines jeunes en changeant
change la couche soit une journée la
culpabilité est là parce qu'on a essayé
les couches lavables justement est aussi
faut accepter ses limites et nous à ce
moment là c'était trop pour nous les
couches lavables j'ai pas ne pas réussi
à introduire dans notre manifeste des
réactions y avait toutes sortes de
choses qui marchait pas des fois ça peut
fonctionner très bien nous ça
fonctionnait pas fait comme moi c'est ma
grande culpabilité les couches j'ai pas
réussi à en rechercher la couche la plus
biodégradables si tel est le cas mais
alors qu'en mai en france mon plus grand
ce sera peut-être un peu plus facile
d'attendre davantage vers les arts nous
aide énormément je parle à des jeunes
familles qui ont des adolescents c'est
eux qui mobilise je peux juste vous
attirer l'attention sur l'or l'or le
brodeur qui a donné une conférence au
festival s est une jeune du collège qui
a approché son école qui a mobilisé une
école au complet pour dire on enlève les
bouteilles de plastique maintenant dans
son école et plus d'école le plastique
c'est juste une jeune fille qui mobilise
et une école au complet c'est des
professeurs c'est une direction c'est
des élèves et des parents d'élèves
donc c'est une étudiante selon jeudi que
le petit geste est important
cette fille là elle lui le cru et le
empêcher sa son école et maintenant ça
fait boule de match
continue chaque enfant retour à la
maison en disant comme la leur au fait
ça qu'est ce que moi je pourrais faire
qu'est ce que moi je pourrais apporter
ses seins il faut y croire et services
sur la culpabilité votre maudit à des
gestes que vous faisiez qui vous sentiez
coupable mais en même temps le mouvement
zéro déchet au début on entendait
beaucoup de discours culpabilisant ouais
c'est quoi votre relation par rapport à
ça vous l'impression que justement le
discours en tête un peu changé et on
permet un peu de latitude
mais je pense que oui parce que
justement on est plusieurs c'est
difficile et j'en parlais justement hier
c'est difficile de refuser
premièrement c'est difficile de refuser
difficile de le dire et je ne serai pas
comme les autres moi je te donne mon sac
c'est arrivé à la boulangerie avec sa
taie d'oreiller dit oui mais témoin tout
mon pain là dedans mais c'est pas tous
les commerçants qui vont faire preuve au
wii vient des fruits offerts comme un
monde où ces liens mais quand c'est fait
la cinquième personne dans sa journée
qui lui dit aux commerçants
mais ça devient naturel pour lui aussi
c'est bien fait que la culpabilité au
début c'est sûr qu'elle est plus grande
parce que c'est dur de changer les
habitudes pas l'impression de changer
juste les tiennes change des autres
aussi en quelques secondes ne reste plus
de temps festival zéro déchet oui leur
activité encore aujourd'hui et autres 50
près de 50 conférences ateliers pour
apprendre shampoing implique plein
d'enfants vraiment être du zéro déchet
dans tout l'événement ciel je le
souligne parce que c'est tellement
important vraiment des conférences sur
de tous les pour tous les goûts un point
pour les enfants et une foire aux
exposants hallucinant pour vous donner
des inspirations que des concerts alors
si on se sent coupable dans notre
consommation voilà on a tellement dit
vous allez repartir de deux ans avec des
objectifs nouveaux je vous le jure
devant dieu merci beaucoup merci à vous